what's up guys i'm colin for thescore
esports
professional league of legends has been
around since mid-2010
and since then we've seen some
incredible rosters rise
and fall now the question is which of
those squads
reigns supreme in the history of league
of legends
it is a tough question to answer but one
we here at the score esports we're up to
taking on
we took into account regional dominance
international performance
and yes impact on a given era to come up
with our list
of the top 10 most dominant league of
legends rosters
of all time coming in at number 10 is a
2013 cloud 9 squad
that burst onto the north american lcs
scene and
changed the way that that regent played
league of legends
balls meteos high sneaky and lemon
nation
dominated their first lcs split
fielding a 25 and three record
on route to an lcs title big special
has used a crescendo has used the
exhaust everything is defensive right
now for tsm to get out and just not hit
the nexus
with their eyes on the nexus their eyes
on the summer split
completely undefeated in the series 25
and three
on the split cloud nine does not drop
a single game in the playoffs that is
the best team in north america after
that
impressive first split this lineup went
on to win
another nalcs title in the 2014 spring
split
as well as back-to-back world's births
in 2013
and 2014.
at number nine we have fnatic's dominant
2015
roster that saw the likes of huni reign
over
fabian reckless and yellow star make
history
as the only european team to go
undefeated
for an entire regular season but the
towers are being fired down bardax his
health bar just evaporates again
hoonie picks up another massive kill as
rekkles takes down the turret
fnatic look to end this game quicker
than we've seen
this entire split and fnatic will become
the first team in lcs history to do it
the perfect split 18-0
greatest team we've ever seen in the lcs
fnatic right now many have called this
team the best roster
the west has ever produced their perfect
18-0 record throughout the 2015 summer
split
translated into yet another eu lcs
championship
and the team would go on to become one
of the first western rosters
to ever finish in the top four at worlds
and number eight are the reigning world
champions
samsung galaxy samsung may not have been
heralded as the best korean roster
heading
in to worlds 2017 but that's what made
their victory
so special cuvee ambition crown
ruler and core jj surprised the entire
world
by doing something that had never been
done
beating faker in a world finals
a game winning pick a championship
winning pick for ruler that might be the
flash r
that signals the end of the skt dynasty
there are no turrets it is five versus
three huni
do you have what it takes to win the
game big
certainly does not ruler on the nexus
the upset is complete as the kills come
through
the skt dynasty is over
all the new kings samsung galaxy
your 2017 world champions
the team not only beat sk telecom in the
finals
but swept the series three consecutive
games
cementing their place in history
our number seven team is the 2015
edition
of china's edward gaming this veteran
squad
consisted of coral one clear love pond
deft and mayco
and became the first non-korean team to
win a major international event
in the lcs era when they defeated skt
in the finals of msi in 2015.
championship bengi bang and wolf now
trying to keep them from being extinct
in the mid-season invitational
here's the last engage edg doesn't even
see the turrets
eyes on skt sk telecom t1 are wiped
the nexus turrets are going down lpl's
edward
gaming are the 2015 mid-season
invitational champions
their msi victory aside this roster
dominated the lpl
winning back to back lpl splits
coming in at number six is korean
powerhouse king zone
dragon x in 2018 the roster consisting
of con
peanut bdd prey and gorilla put up
a whopping 16 and two record in the lck
and continued that momentum into the
playoffs on route to an lck title
oh boy you need too much damage too this
could be the end of it peanuts able to
take out the top catch
now jumping in he gets one kill onto the
morgana doesn't matter it's only the
morgana the
ga gonna come on in here and daddy just
go girl can't do it
they're to take about a dozen smokely
the ace into the end of it all
and it looks like king's own dragon x as
the nexus goes down
will be your lck 2018 spring split
champions
during that season members of kingzone
made up four of the top 10
kda rankings in the region this roster
is the consensus best team
on the planet right now and they are the
odds-on favorite to take home
this year's msi title
before the lcs was formed competitive
league of legends
was very different and nobody embodied
this unique style
more than moscow 5. in an era where
everyone was trying to stall out the
game
darion diamond prox alex each genji and
gosu pepper
ran right down their enemies throats and
closed out games
in under 30 minutes this was their era
this was when they had the most vitality
the most forced the most impact on the
game and they really
they were the best team in the world
they were dominating like when i first
saw them at those first iems they were
like
getting wins in 20 minutes even against
the best teams in the world they were
making teams just
embarrass them they couldn't take him
down it allowed the rest of his team to
get there
alex ish or genji he was all the way in
the bottom lane he ran all the way
up to meet up with shen and they take
home the victory m5 they will move on to
the winners branches start to have to
consider fanning out
but they still have catarina they have
ezreal they have a zillion and a number
of other
strategies that they could run and there
is the game number one m5 takes down
meat playground
sk doing what they can to shut down this
fight too much damage is being dealt
genja back up from the guardian angel
they are focusing on the nexus
turning it around they will be able to
grab it
moscow 5 is your european regional
champion
during their reign of terror in 2012
they won the iem season six world
championship
and iem kiev in addition to 11 other
tournaments at number four we've got the
2016 edition of the rox tigers
sure smeb peanut kuro prey and gorilla
ultimately played second fiddle to skt
but the tigers put up some of the most
impressive results
we've ever seen rox finished first
overall
even above skt in both the 2016 spring
and summer split regular seasons
bringing home the lck
title in the summer this group of
players that had either retired
or been rejected by other teams comes in
no big sponsor
no big team house it's not necessary
because they are going to win
lck summer and they are going to get
a spot in worlds again there it is rox
tigers take it
gg it's about time and that is it
third time is the charm in korea for the
tigers
they finally overcome their curse first
place
is theirs despite the fact that they
were never able to win a major
international title
prey gorilla and company deserve to be
considered
among the game's best at number three
we've got sk telecom t1k
and let's be honest you knew it was
coming
in 2013 skt won the season three world
championship
with faker in the mid lane impact in the
top lane
banking in the jungle piglet at adc and
pumandu at support they beat the kt
rollster bullets to bring home the
korean regional title
and then set their eyes on the world
championship continuously get the fight
piglet got jumped the waters on him and
they're now absolutely running for the
fountain
this does not look good for royal this
doesn't exist crescendo catches all of
them it's a double for impact they get
on the fountain
sk telecom are just rolling through the
nexus turrets are potentially going to
go down
this could be a 20 minute game for sk
telecom
they will be the season three world
champions here at the staples center
their world's victory and 15-3 combined
record at the event
was truly a turning point in pro league
that led to the era of skt dominance
that we know so well today
at number two we have the team that put
up the most convincing world
championship performance
the game has ever seen samsung white
looper dandy pawn imp and mata
made up one of the strongest lineups in
the game's history
and they battled hard with samsung blue
during championship summer
2014 in korea but ultimately
finished third but when it came to
worlds they were able to settle into the
patch
and their hyper aggressive play and
incredible vision control
made them unstoppable on the game's
biggest stage
they come into the series as the heavy
favorites and we've seen them
absolutely dominate the competition
throughout worlds and to say that
samsung white has been dominant is
absolutely an understatement they've
taken out the number one chinese north
american
and korean seeds throughout this entire
tournament only dropping a single game
it's huge and they may just try to win
this
but they were actually pushing that
super minion wave through and samsung
white
are on towards the nexus so it's look at
the damage that they have there
the first texas story is gonna fall only
lulu really there to stop them the
second
story they're gonna focus in on the
nectars itself
and samsung white and the 2014
world champions
coming in at number one is the best of
all skt's dominant lineups the core
of faker wolf bang and bengi have
collected the most impressive body of
work
in the history of league of legends this
team
won the world championship in 2015 with
marin in the top lane
as well as both the spring and summer
lck
playoffs that year that same core was
able to do it all again
in 2016 with the addition of duke over
marin in the top lane
and blank as a secondary jungler chomps
down to kill crowd
sk telecom i've got two make that three
kills
the curtain call is a fitting end to the
world championship and samsung galaxy
are being dove under their tower sk
telecom have overcome
every challenge they are the undisputed
best team in the world the skt reign
continues
they win their third world championship
the organization was
unstoppable and set the bar for what it
means
to dominate okay guys that's our list
now if your favorite league of legends
roster did not make the cut
feel free to make your case in the
comments below i will see you
next week thanks for watching if you
want more great content just like this
be sure to hit the subscribe button